how do you do that do what you always
make me feel better uh well thank you
[Music]
great night
it's amazing what one act of Civil
Disobedience can do for you
I mean there's a whole world that's
waiting to be driven too we could go to
Canada
we got a new battery what's stopping us
you know I think Canada closes at 9 30.
you know I never would have done this if
you hadn't talked me into it
I don't talk even anything
I'm gonna call it a day
good night
by the way
thanks for the ride
what was that for
I just wanted to see what it was like
[Music]
what was it like
over there
wasn't ready for it
what would you have done differently
I don't know
something with my lips
sounds good let's try that next time
when exactly is next time
good night
yeah I'm Really Gonna sleep after that
foreign
dancing what a surprise yeah who knew
yeah you look like you're having a
pretty good time yeah well you know
disco fever you catch it but I'm better
now
wow what a it's what a weird night hey
did you see Kelso shoes yeah remember
when he saw that girl wearing the same
shoes
that was actually that was pretty sad
yeah
hey
um do you recall that night we crossed
the Rio Grande what I can see it in your
eyes what are you talking about how
proud you were to fight for freedom in
this land shut up don't don't there was
something in the air that night the
stars were bright
[Music]
I'm sorry I hate dance music
why'd you go
I like you
so you're in like with me
I'm I'm in
I Can't Dance
you'll learn
that was something in the air that night
the Stars I really want to kiss you
again Fernando Shut Up and Dance
[Music]
foreign
Jackie and Kelso certainly made
themselves comfortable
it's a roomy car
yeah it is
you know the bench seat in the Vista
Cruiser
[Applause]
the same as what's in a full-size
Pontiac well that's interesting
[Applause]
[Music]
um
about tomorrow night
I was thinking that maybe you and I
could go out to dinner for Valentine's
Day oh a Hyatt asked me to study at the
library
well I mean you can do that anytime
right
um yeah yeah I'd love to go
it's great um
so then it's a it's a date
our first yeah
if you don't count all the times I
mauled you yeah
um which I don't so thanks for uh
holding my hair when I was oh
yeah just
thanks for missing my shoes
yeah I guess I blew our big night no no
look it's cool I mean I thought I was
gonna blow it and then I mean you
totally blew it so I mean that's great
you know by telling me I blew it you
basically just blow it
and I was doing so good here with the
jacket and the coffee and holding your
hair bag
I was so in
you're still on
look Donna I want to be your boyfriend
and you're all I ever think about will
you wear my class ring
yes yes
you know
why don't we kiss on it later oh right
then vomiting
no wait you know what I don't care
you're my girlfriend
[Music]
[Applause]
hang on hang on Big Stain big stain on
it
I'm just gonna go grab a towel okay
okay
oh good God
you know they say they're more scared of
you than you were them boys
you know Donna I've thought about this
moment like
a thousand times
me too
[Applause]
[Music]
hey when you thought about this moment
was it like this
not really
you know I was having a pretty good time
at prom
foreign
let's get out of here
okay
um
Donna what if this is our only chance
it won't be
what's what's wrong you're like a
million miles away
I don't know I don't know it's just that
my parents are fighting like all the
time
this makes me so mad
like I want to kick their asses but I
can't but I want to do something
okay
take me Donna what
go ahead take me punish your parents by
using me for sex do your business and be
done with it go ahead don't be shy
I didn't actually think that was gonna
work did you
no but I'm a virgin it's driving me
crazy
but that's not your fault no wait yes it
is
how do you do that do what you always
make me feel better
um well thank you
I love you Eric
I love cake
[Applause]
Eric Eric are you okay
what yeah
yeah you look like you have a stomach
ache or something
no
there's nothing wrong with my stomach
it's just that
I love you
man
great shot
and I love you
well the basket doesn't really count
because I traveled you could never
travel
because I love you
Eric you're acting like a huge dork
a huge shark who loves you
stop it all right
somebody said it is because felt it
and not just so you'd say it back
and if I knew you were going to get such
a Twist about it I wouldn't have said it
at all I'm not in a Twist it's just
cake okay that was pretty stupid yes
why'd you say it
say it I don't know I just
now once it
is out there if we broke up I mean
you know what would I tell myself then
I guess you could tell yourself you
still have cake we both know how much it
means to you
that's nice there's a sweet girl
Midge and I would like to thank everyone
for coming
really means a lot to us
the valves were exchanging were written
by our daughter Donna
whom we love very much
midgey
I consider it a privilege to be your
husband
Donna I actually feel that way
Bob I'm proud and very grateful to be
your wife
we've known each other since we were
practically kids so we know all the good
stuff
and all the not so good stuff about each
other I can't imagine feeling about
anyone else the way I feel about you
because I love you
I always loved you and I want to make
you a promise
no matter what happens
good or bad I Will Always Love You
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
okay Donna wait what
well first you dragged me away from the
wedding and then you kissed me all the
way over here and then you pull me
upstairs and shove me into my bedroom
and put your hands all over my body I
just
I'm sorry I'm confused
if only they're a way to make my
feelings clear with some sort of action
yeah okay that's uh ah it's extremely
funny but uh
every time this starts happening
it winds up not happening and then you
skip home
I know I know and I'm sorry it's just
you know before now I wasn't ready yeah
and I understand that Donna it's just
that wait wait go back
I wasn't ready before now
before now like
right now
Eric when I had to write those vows
I had to think about love when I thought
about love I thought about you
I love you Eric and I want to be with
you
God Donna I
love you
are you
sure sure
yes yes
[Music]
I wanted to talk to you
be hard yeah
um
Eric I love you
a lot
but I have to give you your ring back
what
why
okay
how do you see the next 20 years
I don't know I guess I always figured
we'd go to college together
and come home yeah but Eric you know
that's not what I want I mean I've told
you that
and who knows I might want to go to
school back east or
maybe in Paris okay well you know what
Donna whatever okay the important thing
is when you see yourself in Paris or
wherever I'm there right
right
I don't know
not always
I mean it's not like there's anyone else
but sometimes I'm by myself
I mean all I mean is I don't know
neither of us does
and this ring is just a stupid High
School promise
if we're meant to be together then we'll
end up together
no
the way we end up together is by saying
we'll be together and then
being together Eric come on
we're together now
isn't that enough
no I mean
I mean damn Donna
if you can see a future for yourself
without me and that doesn't like break
your heart then I we're not doing what I
thought we were doing here and you know
what
maybe we shouldn't even be together at
all
wait a minute
are you breaking up with me
well
are you giving back that ring
then
yes
foreign
[Music]